j'ai pas pu m'occuper de mon frère était
comme abandonné difficile pour pierre
être langevin d'imaginer les terres ni
moment de son frère robert langevin
était en attente de procès au centre de
détention de bordeaux à montréal quand
la prison a été frappé de plein fouet
par la kfw 19 l'établissement confine
les détenus à leur cellule après avoir
trouvé un premier cas des semaines plus
tard la famille reçoit un appel
robert est mort après avoir contracté le
virus d'un choc
c'est comme plonger pour puis parler
comme à ceux qui ont peu répondu qu'ils
étaient six à vingt six au à 72 ans et
souffrant de problèmes de santé
robert langevin avait lancé un cri du
coeur deux mois avant son décès dans une
plainte déposée auprès du protecteur du
citoyen il écrivait je ne veux pas
mourir ici je suis un cas urgent est
vulnérable j'ai des droits selon nos
recherches au pays plus de 600 personnes
en détention ont été déclarées positives
à la coved 19 depuis le début de la
pandémie et trois en sont mortes
notre analyse de données nationale
révèlent que les taux d'infection à la
coved 19 ans prisons provinciales et
fédérales sont cinq à neuf fois plus
élevé que dans la population générale
est détenu et des employés de plusieurs
prisons au pays nous ont confié ne pas
se sentir en sécurité
l'un d'entre eux récemment détenu à
bordeaux a appris qu'il était porteur du
virus seulement après sa sortie de
prison
le ministère de la sécurité publique du
québec dit avoir rendu le port du masque
obligatoire pour le personnel à partir
du mois de mai et avoir amélioré son
système de dépistage la sécurité
publique et le coroner du québec ont
ouvert une enquête sur les allégations
de négligence en lien avec la mort de
robert langevin moi j'oublie le
prisonnier
je jouais juste l'homme mon frère tu
comprends la bâtisse ou skier je vois
pas vraiment vrac qui plante qui veut se
faire soigner dionne valérie aux lettres
du canada à montréal